you want to jump into a little bit of a
deep dive into the armor systems within
Diablo 4 so Hmong like take us through
it yeah sure I'm happy to talk about the
armor system so in Diablo 4 armored is
the major way for player to mitigate
incoming damage especially physical
damage
the major way for people to acquire
armor is through the five armor slots
they are Helm chest pants boots and
gloves and mostly for Fantasy reason we
made armor chest armor and pants provide
the most armor value well boots and
gloves provide the the smallest amount
of armor value
um
armor
in the armor value on the item is
depends on depends on the the I the
item's power and in Diablo we use the
item power value to represent the power
of the item yeah and I don't think we've
talked a lot about how item power Works
can you describe what it means for the
lf4 yeah so in Diablo 4 the item when
they when they start dropping it's based
on the it's based on the Monsters uh
Monster Power and we need a value to
represent how powerful this is like when
you start getting more challenging
content in the later World here you'll
use you'll see uh you you'll get more
and more powerful items and we need
something to to evaluate that then and
represent that power so we use the item
power to represent that power and you
can see that on the items 2 tip and if
you like you can compare the two items
if the item has a higher item power that
means
uh that item most likely going to be
more powerful than the lower item
forward but not always right not always
the specific affixes or things that are
especially powerful for your build yeah
exactly
and back to the armor value the armor
value actually directly tied to this
item power on on the arm items
it's actually skating linearly with the
item power the higher the item power the
more armor value that item provides
and that's so that we know that you have
we have some baseline for how much
damage mitigation the player has exactly
because because of this when you loot
higher power items you naturally gain
higher amount of armor and therefore
it's guaranteed you always have a
certain amount of damage mitigation
against
physical damage
and so uh yeah so armor Works
differently in Diablo 4 than it did in
Diablo 3 right yeah particularly for
Elemental resistances yeah exactly like
in Diablo 4
um
we so this is this is kind of like a
long story like we uh we because of the
mechanic we made sure the item uh the
player have a certain amount of uh
damage mitigation against the physical
damage but then we found out
um some monster they they are doing
non-physical damage and that caused
trouble for the for the player like for
example there's a there's a denim boss
only deal Shadow damage and that caused
some serious balance problem for the
encounter team because
for people who have a reasonable amount
of Shadow resistant the boss is not that
hard but some people like when they have
zero Shadow resistance uh the boss is
almost unbeatable like they will always
get one shot for the for this boss
and players at low level they might not
have access to as much Shadow resistance
you might not be as familiar with the
game exactly
so to solve this problem uh what we did
is we made some change to the armor
system so armor not only absorb
or mitigate incoming physical damage we
also make make
it absorbs a certain amount of
non-physical damage so how it works is
like this for whatever percentage the
armor of the physical damage it also
absorbs half of the that amount of
non-physical damage for example your
armor absorb 60 physical damage
so your armor will also absorb 30
percent of all the nine feet of damage
so fire damage Shadow damage so on
exactly and and because of this
people know also getting some among them
not a big amount but some amount of uh
mitigation against non-thetical damage
so that shadow balls
it's still challenging for people with
zero Shadow resistance but it's in a
much more uh controllable way
and as players level up and they get
access to higher World tiers those
worlds here is actually uh have a
penalty to your Elemental resistances
right so you're going to have to really
make sure that you're keeping up on
those resistances yeah exactly
um when you get to higher wood here
um
we we added more penalty for the players
to make the higher World here more
challenging and so you will have a uh we
we put some 20
uh penalty uh from uh from Water 2 to
World tier three
for the resistance so you you gain 20
less resistance and from World tier 3 to
World tier 4 we put even higher penalty
it's 40 so 44 will be a lot more
challenging than what history
but players have access as they're
getting up into those higher levels
they're also getting access to more
sources of Elemental resistance right
yeah exactly
um we we added a uh the elemental
resistance into Wireless uh in-game
system like skill tree like item affixes
like a paragon system you can acquire
those uh uh those uh resistance through
uh more and more weight we actually
expose more and more weight for you to
be able to acquire armor and resistance
at the end game so I think you brought
some charts to show like in more detail
how the mitigation Works sure so uh we
have talked about like all the all the
basic or how armor works I want to dive
a little bit deeper into actually how
armor affect players uh gameplay
experience from level to level uh the
first thing I want to talk about is at
each level we have a expected armor I do
for player and based on that we
calculate what's the damage reduction
player can get at each level and we
balance the monster damage above that
and from this chart you can see at the
beginning you
based on the expected armor value you
can only get like a little above 10
damage reduction but it goes up pretty
fast and either at the late game you can
get like over 40 damage reduction from
the armor value it makes sense to fight
to quantity wise because like I think
about it at the beginning you have only
this light leather pants it absorbs a
very small amount of damage but at a
later level you get this epic played
armor that absorb a lot more
um
because of this uh because of this like
the the the Diamond reduction uh going
up uh player also uh that means that we
need to uh make the the the monster deal
more and more damage to mitigate this
damn reduction for the player
and this is next I'm gonna talk about
like a uh how actually each uh unit
armor uh of door damage from Level
flower yeah because I think we have
another graph here
um that goes through yeah the armor so
you see like uh it's opposite to how
much damage reduction we expect for
player to get from Level from level
level it's from lower to higher but
actually the time reduction per armor is
going down with level so per point of
armor that I have
this is the chart that shows how much
damage reduction that one what single
point of armor gives me yes at a given
level okay
um and at the beginning like you can see
from this chart like every 100 armor
kind of absorb about the five percent of
them reduction but it goes down
um pretty fast early and slow down at
the end and at the end you can see it
like each one 100 armor can only absorb
uh one percent damage reduction
um we we make it uh work this way
because we want to make sure that
Designer have room to add more armor
bonus at endgame at the end game uh we
try to avoid the situation like at the
beginning you get to a pretty good
amount of armor then you totally forgot
about this
um uh like early on we talk about the we
add we added like a resistant penalty to
to a four player from World here at wood
here that's actually for a very similar
purpose because of this penalty uh even
though you have a pretty good resistance
either early game you still need to look
for more resistance either at a late
game and there are other ways that
players can get them introduction too in
addition to armor right yep exactly
um not only that they get this uh
that's a kind of like happened at the
late game when the challenges starts
they need to find a lot of other way
like they can look for uh like a for
solder class they can look for energy
shield for Druid and Barbarian the local
45 power and for uh for a yoga class
they look for more dark chance so not
only they build on the armor and
resistance to mitigate the damage at the
late game because the challenge becomes
so so tough the world becomes the
monster is so so harsh they need to find
the multiple way to be able to survive
in this harsh world
uh so far I have been talking about like
all all of this is one player fighting
uh the equal level monster so uh so next
I'm gonna talk like like what if you
fight against a different level monster
if a monster higher than you or Monster
lower than you so this chart shows a
player with 2000 armor
uh what happened how much damage
reduction it actually absorbs for for
that 2000 armor uh when they fight
against different level monsters
and you can see like the higher the
monster level is uh the less Demi
reduction
this Tucson armor actually absorb and
you can see like at the lower level
they're actually already like reached
the the dam reduction cap we said for
armor which is 85 percent
but I when you like uh for 2000 armor
usually the player can come across the
this amount of armor around the level 30
right but if you see this level 30
character when they fight a level 100
monster the 2000 armor can actually only
absorb five percent of the incoming
damage which is pretty minimum so that
means
when you run a player for them to
challenge a higher level Monster not
only the monster deal more damage
they also penetrate more of your
of your armor so I'm gonna need more
armor as I level up yeah yep uh during
during level of a campaign like while
you're doing campaign how you do the
open world content it's not a big issue
because the motor monster skill with you
but when you when you do uh the end game
content like a nightmare dungeon or Hell
tied a lot of times you're forced to
fight to fight higher level monster and
in those cases uh
you you will take like this building
punishment
to for the player so so you you you you
you need to like uh find a way to
mitigate that the the more damage some
people like they build up their
offensive power they try to finish the
combat faster so that they can take less
damage while other people they find all
the way like like beside going through a
paragon system skill tree automatics is
uh and the Legendary Power of all the
using all the ways to mitigate that uh
punishment we also uh added uh damage
mitigation to monsters in Diablo 4 right
yeah yeah exactly that's uh that's what
I want to talk about
um so we used to not have a damage uh
mitigation for Monster so monsters are
used to not have armor so
um however amount the damage player
deals that's Howard uh amount of damage
the monster gonna take so it had a
Advantage it's pretty straightforward
it's really easy to understand
but it also has a problem that is
whenever we want to increase the
monsters the defense power the only only
way we can do it is through increasing
the monster's hit point
um like we say like we say from a level
31 a monster from level 31 to 32 we want
to increase the their defined power of
the time to kill by 10 that means level
32 months are gonna have uh 10 more uh
hit point of life
than the level 31 monster if you do this
from Level 1 to level 100 and at the end
it ends up with a a super big number
like a billions or even trillions
and for people for players to be able to
kill this monster in a reasonable time
the player needs to have deal like
billions of damage
um
and in Diablo 4 we we show the statement
number as the floating combat text we
cannot hide it and so the the because
the number is so big so long it covers a
big chunk of the screen yeah it's hard
to understand too like yeah reading is
you know combat and Diablos really fast
you want to be able to quickly
understand how much damage you're doing
yes
um and we're trying to keep the numbers
down yeah we we try to solve this
problem also we get a lot of feedback
from Community they also they also don't
like this yeah I know the comedians
talked a lot about like big damage
numbers and so forth in like like Diablo
3 for instance and so forth so yeah yeah
so uh so therefore we decided to add
this damage mitigation or we call the
monster armor so at each level uh
monster actually absorb a certain
percentage of uh players damage it's
pretty low at the early level and it
goes up at a at a later level then in
our play test with increase is a a
different problem because because this
stem reduction going up pretty fast
player actually deal less damage when
they level up that's that's not what we
want I don't want to get weaker when I
level up yeah exactly so we have to take
the time reduction number for the
monster so that it always scales slower
compared to the damage increase
damage increase for the player so it
it's players damage deal to the monster
still
increased from level to level but now we
have a pretty good way to control how
fast it increase and therefore we we get
the damage number at a very late game
into a pretty reasonable space it's good
that's awesome